This is the brief on portable
wealth and local taxation.
OK, so the big idea, the days
when wealth was stuck in one
place, those are over capitals,
super mobile now, you know, and
it's this powerful force,
governments just can't strong
arm anymore.
So how is this shift really
changing the tax game?
Well, there are three key things
going on. 1st money just feels
different.
It used to be heavy locked in
factories letting governments
slap on huge tax rates.
But now deregulation, fiber
optics monies like vapor zips
across borders instantly, almost
impossible to trap.
Second, local governments got to
be careful.
Crank up the heat with tough
taxes or rent control.
They risk an exit.
We're talking the productive
folks, maybe dual income
families making good money
funding schools.
They see high taxes as opt out.
They'll just move NYC to the
burbs.
DC folks over the river.
They don't stick around to
fight.
And finally, taxation isn't
coercion now, it's courtship.
Since wealth can walk, cities
have to woo capital.
They compete with tax breaks,
new infrastructure.
Think Amazon's HQ 2.
Sometimes it's urban alchemy.
Big projects like stadiums
become excuses to revitalize,
attract prestige and boost the
tax base.
So yeah, the contest for money,
it's gravitational.
Governments need to realize they
orbit wealth because that
productive class loyalty.
It's not the 19th century
anymore.
Really interesting take on how
wealth mobility is changing the
game for cities and their
biggest taxpayers.
Yeah, it paints a clear picture,
this idea that wealth isn't tied
down anymore.
It's like vapor.
Exactly vapor.
It just dissolves geography,
right?
Show companies digital
transfers.
Gives the wealthy and capital
itself huge leverage over
cities.
So the framing is this shift
from, you know, cities telling
taxpayers what to do to cities
having to sort of court them.
That's the core of it.
It's a fascinating setup.
Let's dive right in and see how
we can maybe push that argument
even further.
Make it even more robust sounds.
Good.
Where do we start?
Well, the first big thought I
had was this.
The essay really nails the
diagnosis.
You know the limits of taxing
mobile wealth.
But it could probably be
stronger on the what next?
The policy pivot for cities.
Right.
It makes a strong case that
cities kind of have to blink
first.
They can't afford to lose what
the writer calls the invisible
scaffolding.
Uh huh.
Those what, 300,400 thousand
dollar households?
Yeah, exactly.
And it shows how those old 8090%
tax rates only worked when
capital was physically stuck.
Factories paperwork.
But those days are gone, so we
get why income taxes are
failing.
OK, so the weakness then?
The weakness, I think, is that
it describes that cycle really
well.
You know, punitive tax people
leave, city offers concessions,
but it kind of stops there.
It diagnosis but doesn't fully
prescribe.
Exactly.
It leaves you wondering, OK, if
high taxes don't work, what are
the levers left for a city that
now has to attract or at least
keep this mobile wealth?
So the suggestion is to shift
the focus away from just showing
what fails.
Yeah, shift from what doesn't
work, the high taxes, the moral
lectures the piece mentions
towards a really pragmatic look
at what modern leverage point
cities still have things that
wealth can't just easily exit.
OK, leverage points that are
harder to escape?
Like what?
Give me some concrete examples.
Well, the writer could explore
things like a specific localized
services, or maybe regulatory
things that capital can't just
bypass.
You mean stuff tied to the
physical place?
Precisely.
Think about geographically
inescapable fees.
Maybe congestion charges or
environmental fees tied directly
to a physical building.
Or, I don't know, localized
consumption prints.
Sometimes, doesn't it?
It has to land somewhere to be
used.
But couldn't that just push,
say, big corporate HQS just
outside the zone where those
fees apply?
Are we just moving the goal
posts?
It's a risk, sure, but maybe
frame it as taxing friction.
The physical stuff, the offices,
the apartments, the
infrastructure they need that's
still grounded.
OK.
So an alternative could be
looking at local control over
essentials, things like
utilities or maybe that last
mile of fiber optic cable?
Ah, the actual pipes and wires.
Exactly, you might not be able
to tax the CE OS income if they
hop between states, but you can
charge your premium for the
Super high speed connection
their trading desk needs in
their downtown office.
So it reframes the city not just
as a tax authority, but as a
service provider for essential
non movable infrastructure.
Precisely, it becomes a client
provider relationship for
certain things.
That seems like a practical
angle to explore more.
That's a really solid
suggestion.
Turns unavoidable local presence
into a potential revenue source.
OK, that makes sense for the
first point.
What's the second area?
The second area is about really
nailing down that idea of vapor.
OK.
The essay does a great job with
the residential flight, the
frogs as it calls them, jumping
out of the pot.
Right.
The people moving from
California to Austin or
wherever, it's vivid.
It is vivid, but the argument
about wealth being vapor could
be even stronger if it more
tightly linked that physical
movement with the non geographic
movement of corporate capital.
Abstract capitals.
Yeah, the piece mentions it.
You know, money flowing through
shells, trusts, subsidiaries,
businesses incorporating in
Delaware while the shop is on
Main Street.
Got it.
So the weakness is.
The weakness is that the story
relies maybe a bit too heavily
on the physical moves Savor into
Singapore, the DC commuters.
It's relatable, but it's
slightly undersells the core
idea that for the biggest pools
of wealth, geography is kind of
already dissolved thanks to
digital transfers and
deregulation.
So it feels like 2 separate
issues almost.
People moving and profits
moving, but not fully woven
together.
Exactly.
It leaves the argument a little
siloed.
You have the visible problem of
the frogs leaving the pot, and
the invisible problem of the
corporate value just hollowing
out.
OK, so the suggestion is to
bridge those two more
explicitly.
Yes, show how cities are getting
hit on both fronts
simultaneously.
They're losing the income tax
from the residents who leave,
and they're being undermined by
the invisible routing of
corporate profits.
The vapor.
Making it clear it's a pincer
movement basically.
Right.
It maximizes the threat level,
justifies that strong title.
It's not just a few unhappy rich
folks leaving.
It's a systemic drain.
So concretely, how could the
piece do that, especially that
hollowing out part?
Well, it could detail more how a
city ends up, you know, chasing
shadows.
Like they can tax the local
coffee shop easily, sure, but
the holding company that owns it
that routes billions through
some low tax jurisdiction?
Much harder.
And then maybe bring in the
newest layer of this.
Which is.
Remote work, post 2020 remote
work, it's like a third wave of
portability, right?
And it challenges that old idea
that, say, high end professional
services needed a prestigious
physical address.
Yeah, the idea that you had to
be physically in London or New
York for reputation.
Exactly.
That was maybe the last tether
for some of these higher
earners.
But now a top lawyer or
consultant can potentially work
from anywhere a low tax state
without losing that New York
lawyer credibility.
And that directly hits the
city's ability to claim
residency based income tax
because the work itself is
becoming detached from the
physical city.
Precisely.
The labor becomes vapor too, in
a way, detached from that
expensive office tower that
needs to be woven in tightly to
show the full scope of the
challenge.
OK.
That really clarified the scale.
Excellent.
So what's the third main point?
The third one is about the the
core philosophy in the
conclusion OK, the essays real
strength is its pragmatic,
almost physics based view of
capital, right Money follows the
path of least resistance, like
water or gravity.
Yeah, I liked that framing.
The rich aren't villains,
they're thermometers reacting to
the environment.
No protest, no slogans, just
arithmetic.
That's a powerful line.
It is powerful and we want to
keep that sharp edge, but the
potential weakness is that the
conclusion leans quite heavily
into the psychology of it all.
How so?
It talks a lot about wooing
taxpayers, avoiding contempt,
the negative effects of rhetoric
like killing billionaires,
suggesting that if cities are
just, well, nicer, capital might
stay.
And that risks making it sound
like it's just about manners or
political tone.
Exactly.
It could slightly dilute that
core deterministic claim that at
the end of the day arithmetic
always wins.
It might sound more like a plea
for better PR than a hard nosed
analysis of cost benefit.
Which undermines the whole
financial gravity argument that
makes the piece so strong.
It suggests if the mayor just
smiles more, the problem solved.
Right.
And is there a risk there?
Does focusing on the emotional
legitimacy angle maybe overlook
the fact that, well, high net
worth people will just move when
the math changes, no matter how
politely the city asks them to
stay?
So the suggestion isn't to
ignore the taxpayer reaction,
but to frame it differently.
Precisely reframe the
psychological bit to actually
reinforce the supremacy of
financial physics.
How would that work in practice?
Present the taxpayers decision
less as a reaction to, you know,
moral outrage or feeling unloved
and more as a purely logical
risk manage response.
Like portfolio management for
where you live?
Exactly, they're just responding
to a deteriorating ROI on
residency.
It's not about hurt feelings,
it's about capitals.
Extreme sensitivity to friction.
The wooing only matters if the
numbers are already close to
making sense.
So concrete examples focus less
on the rhetoric and more on the
triggers.
Yes.
Focus less on the moral lectures
that, you know, raise the
temperature, and more on the
specific, concrete policy
actions that instantly change
the math.
Like a sudden change in property
tax assessment.
Perfect example.
Or a new state fee that wasn't
well communicated and hits high
value assets hard.
That stuff immediately shifts
the arithmetic.
And causes the exit regardless
of whether the mayor sent a nice
letter.
Right.
It reinforces that idea of the
Princess and the P class.
They're exquisitely sensitive to
financial friction, not just
harsh words.
Keep the argument cold.
Calculating physics based right
to the very end.
OK, that feels like a much
tighter way to land the
conclusion consistent with the
core thesis.
This has been really helpful.
Good.
So just to recap the three big
opportunities we discussed.
First, broadening the policy
analysis beyond just income tax,
looking at those inescapable
location based friction points.
Right.
Taxing friction through things
like infrastructure access or
usage fees.
Second, really integrating the
vapor of abstract capital and
remote work with the story of
physical residential flight
showing the combined threat.
Uh huh.
Connecting the invisible
hollowing out with the visible
exodus.
And 3rd, recalibrating the
conclusion to keep the focus
firmly on the cold arithmetic,
the financial physics, rather
than letting it drift too much
into psychological appeals or
political tone.
Exactly.
Frame taxpayer sensitivity as a
logical ROI calculation
triggered by concrete policy
changes, not just rhetoric.
The actionable takeaways seem
clear.
Then analyze that non tax
leverage, detail the full scope
of portability, including
corporate structures and remote
work, and keep the final
argument grounded in that
pragmatic, ROI driven reality.
Sounds like a plan.
The piece is already strong,
very insightful.
Absolutely.
It's got a powerful voice in a
fresh angle.
These suggestions are really
just about maximizing this
completeness and ensuring the
policy implications are as
robust as the diagnosis.
Agreed.
We definitely invite the writer
to consider these points, refine
the piece, and of course, feel
free to submit it back again.
Today we're really getting into
something fundamental, the
nature of modern wealth, how it
moves, why it moves, and maybe
most importantly, it's
incredible ability to just
vanish when it feels, well,
unwelcome.
We're calling this one the
portable power of wealth.
And you know, sometimes the best
starting point is almost the
most unlikely one.
Our source material actually
kicks off with this anecdote
from Believed or Not, a social
media comment section.
Someone challenged the writer
basically saying name one time
rich people actually moved just
to avoid taxes.
Ah.
Yes, that old chestnut, it pops
up all the time, doesn't it?
This.
This fundamental disbelief that
wealth, especially the big
generational or corporate kind,
can actually pack its bags and
leave.
People see buildings, they see
factories, and they think, OK,
the money's stuck here.
They equate the physical stuff
with the the financial reality,
fiscal immobility, as you put
it.
Exactly, but the sources just
immediately knocked that down
the moment you ask the question.
The examples just, well, they
flood in.
It's not even hard to find them.
Right, like example #1 pretty
famous one.
Eduardo Savrin, the Facebook Co
founder.
The classic modern case, really.
He renounced his US citizenship
move to Singapore.
And the timing just just before
Facebook's massive IPO, We're
talking about a move that likely
saved him, well, potentially
billions in taxes.
That wasn't, you know, about the
weather in Singapore.
No, that was a spreadsheet
decision, pure and simple, made
by someone at the absolute top
of the tech game.
And he's just the tip of the
iceberg.
Really.
You don't even need to look
globally.
Just look inside the US right
now.
The shifts are enormous.
You mean the California exodus
narrative, that kind of thing?
Well.
It's more than a narrative,
isn't it?
It's happening.
You see this steady stream,
sometimes a flood of high net
worth folks, entrepreneurs,
entire companies moving out of
high tax places like California
and where do they go?
Austin and Miami seem to be the
big winners, or at least the
most talked about.
They are.
Austin is maybe the cliche now,
but it's grounded in reality.
And Miami, it's fundamentally
changed.
It's become this huge financial
center largely fueled by that
migration from the Northeast in
California.
And these aren't just people
buying winter condos.
It's permanent relocation.
It's human capital voting with
its feet.
And then you get the really
dramatic international examples,
like the French actor Gerard
Depardue.
Our sources brought him up.
That was quite the performance.
Oh, absolutely.
When France hiked its top tax
rate significantly, he didn't
just, you know, complain to his
friends.
He made a huge public spectacle
of it.
He moved to Belgium first,
right?
Lower taxes there.
Yes, and then almost like a
calculated insult to Paris, he
took up Russian citizenship and
he specifically publicly cited
Russia's low flat tax rate as
the reason it was a signal
flare.
He was basically saying, look,
if you make taxes feel punitive,
we have options, we can leave.
And he made sure everyone knew
it.
So the common idea that wealth
is tied down, anchored, it's
just not the reality anymore.
It's incredibly fluid, maybe
even hyper mobile.
That's the core premise we have
to accept to even start this
conversation.
OK, so our mission today in this
deep dive isn't really to debate
if the rich move.
That seems pretty clear.
It's more about the how and the
what.
How did capital get so portable?
And what does this freedom, this
physical mobility, actually mean
for cities, for taxes, for how
governments even function?
Exactly.
Understanding that shift in the,
let's call it the physics of
capital is crucial because it
leads directly to this paradox,
the source points out.
When a city tries to push its
upper class financially, they
don't really fight back in the
traditional sense.
They don't organize protests or
lobby heavily leave.
They just leave quietly,
efficiently, They move.
And that completely changes the
power dynamic between the
governor and the government.
There was that interesting
example from New York City
recently, the election of Zoran
Mamdani.
He ran on a pretty ambitious
progressive platform, right?
Things like universal rent
freezes, big public housing
pushes.
Very ambitious and policies like
that, they obviously require
significant funding, which means
inevitably higher taxes on the
wealthy, residents and
corporations.
And the reaction wasn't just
political debate in the City
Council.
It was faster than that, more
immediate.
It bypassed politics almost
entirely.
The anxiety hit the private
market instantly.
The sources highlighted these
immediate, tangible signs.
You saw headlines suddenly
screaming about bidding wars for
houses up in Westchester County.
Listings in wealthy parts of
Connecticut, like Greenwich,
suddenly getting tons of
interest.
And Realtors in New Jersey
apparently had their phones
ringing off the hook.
Right.
It's like a collective, almost
subconscious flight response
kicking in.
It shows that the decision isn't
about abstract loyalty to the
city.
It's a gut reaction to a
perceived threat to their
financial comfort zone.
A kind of fiscal thermometer.
As you said, the needle spikes
and people start looking for the
exits even before a policy is
actually enacted.
Precisely.
The planning starts, the calls
are made, the Zillow searches
happened.
The moment the rhetoric heats
up, it tells you the calculation
is pragmatic, not ideological.
OK, that really sets the stage.
Let's dig into how we got to
this point.
Section 2, The physics of
capital from heavy metal to
vapor.
Because to really get why
today's wealth is so mobile, we
need to understand why
yesterday's wasn't.
Absolutely.
You have to go back to what the
sources call the era of heavy
money.
I think roughly 1940s through
the 1970s.
It seems almost unbelievable
now, but back then the US,
Western Europe, they can sustain
incredibly high top marginal tax
rates.
Yeah, numbers that sound crazy
today, 70 percent, 80%, even
over 90% in the US at the peak.
How is that even possible?
Why didn't everyone just leave
them?
Well, the short answer is they
couldn't.
Not easily anyway.
The source make it clear the
physics were different.
Money was, in a very real sense,
physically trapped.
It was bound by layers of legal
and infrastructural friction
that just don't exist anymore.
What kind of friction?
What held it down?
Well, first think about where
wealth came from.
Mostly physical assets, owning a
steel mill, controlling port
infrastructure, running a big
factory complex.
That stuff was bolted to the
ground.
Right.
A Rockefeller couldn't just
decide on a whim to move
standard oils refineries to,
say, Panama, could they?
The cost and complexity would
have been astronomical.
Exactly.
The physical anchor was immense,
but it wasn't just the physical
stuff.
The whole global financial
system was designed to prevent
easy movement of capital.
The legal framework.
Yes, the Britton Woods system
specifically. after World War 2,
the goal was stability.
That meant regulated exchange
rates and critically stripped
controls on capital flows
between countries.
Moving serious money
internationally wasn't just a
matter of clicking a button.
It was a bureaucratic nightmare,
I imagine.
A huge one Layers of paperwork,
government approvals, currency
controls, significant
transaction costs.
That source image of the French
banker in 1955 needing a cargo
ship to physically move a large
amount of francs offshore.
That perfectly captures the
sheer weight, the immobility of
capital back then.
A.
Whole cargo ship.
It's hard to even picture now.
So that was the world of heavy
money, fixed, anchored.
But then, as the sources say,
the shackles snapped.
Money became vapor.
What broke the chains?
He was really a confluence of
factors hitting around the same
time starting in the late 70s
and really accelerating in the
80s and 90s.
You can break it down into maybe
3 big things, deregulation,
technology, and logistics.
OK, let's take deregulation
first.
That sounds like it removed the
legal barriers.
Pretty much there was this
global wave of financial
deregulation.
Countries wanted to attract
international finance, so they
started dismantling those
Bretton Woods area capital
controls.
They opened up their capital
accounts about things like the
repeal of Glass Steagall in the
US, similar moves in the UK and
elsewhere.
Suddenly the legal permission to
move money freely was there.
The paperwork hurdles started
vanishing.
And then technology provided the
means the speed.
Exactly.
Fiber optic cable spreading
everywhere, Computers getting
exponentially more powerful.
Financial transactions went from
taking days or weeks involving
physical transfers to being
instantaneous.
Digital wealth wasn't gold bars
in a vault anymore, it was
electrons numbers on a screen.
And those numbers could be moved
anywhere in the world before
breakfast, as the source puts
it.
Literally the cost of moving
vast sums dropped from, well,
the cost of chartering a ship to
practically 0.
The physical friction just
evaporated.
OK, so deregulation open the
door tech provided the speed.
What about logistics?
You mentioned container ships,
how did they play a role?
They move goods, not money,
directly.
But they enabled something
crucial the hyper optimization
of global supply chains.
Yes, container ships made moving
physical goods incredibly cheap
and efficient, but that
efficiency allowed multinational
corporations to structure their
operations in incredibly complex
ways specifically designed to
minimize taxes.
Well, you could manufacture
components in country A, high
tax, maybe ship them via
container to country B, low tax
for some minor assembly or just
processing, and then book the
final sale and the bulk of the
profit in country CA-0 tax
haven.
You could legally shift where
the profit was recognized by
carefully managing where
ownership transferred, often
while the goods were literally
still on the ship.
So the container ship
facilitated tax avoidance
strategies essentially by making
the physical movement of goods
so fluid and cheap.
Precisely, it allowed the
financial engineering to align
perfectly with the optimized
physical logistics.
OK, so you put it all together.
Deregulation, instant digital
transfers, hydro efficient
global logistics.
The anchor is well and truly
gone.
And the sources argue this just
completely flips the power
dynamic between governments and
capital.
Completely reverses it.
The leverage shifts almost
entirely to the owners of
capital.
And that observation in the
source material is so sharp.
Whenever a politician gets up
and makes that promise, we're
going to make the rich pay their
fair share.
You could almost predict what
happens next.
It turns into a game of chicken.
The government threatens higher
taxes or more regulation.
And capital threatens to leave.
And the government, the city,
the state, they almost always
blink first.
Why?
Why do they blink?
Because the potential
consequences of capital flight
are catastrophic for their
budgets.
We're not talking about
thousands and thousands of
people needing to leave.
Sometimes it's just a few
hundred key taxpayers or one or
two major corporations deciding
to relocate their headquarters.
The fiscal hole that opens up is
immediate.
It's huge.
You can't just fill it by taxing
the remaining population more.
They might leave too, but they
simply don't have enough income.
Especially if it's like crucial
upper middle class, that 300 K
$400.00 professional bracket we
mentioned if they get nervous.
Their departure cripples the
funding for schools, for
transit, for everything.
The city faces an immediate
budget crisis.
So the government blinks and
what happens then?
Do things just go back to
normal?
Rarely.
What usually follows is the
charm offensive.
Instead of demanding more, the
city starts offering
concessions.
You see new tax credits rolled
out, maybe special enterprise
zones created, billions offered
for things like Amazon's HQ 2.
They actively try to lure the
wealth back or keep it from
leaving in the first place.
The source had that great image
trying to coax the frogs back
into the pot.
Exactly.
And here's the kicker.
Often when the wealth does come
back or decides to stay, it's on
better terms than before.
They've successfully used the
threat of leaving to negotiate a
sweeter deal.
Lower taxes, less friction.
They get rewarded for their
mobility.
Which just reinforces the power
dynamic even further in their
favor.
It's a cycle where the
government keeps giving away
leverage.
It is, which leads us nicely
into looking more closely at who
these really crucial mobile
frogs are.
Section 3 The thermometer class.
Who moves and why?
Because it's easy to just
picture billionaires on yachts.
But the source says the real
pressure point day-to-day isn't
necessarily them.
Right.
It's not just the Jeff Bezos or
Elon Musk figures, although they
matter.
It's a broader group.
It's what the source calls the
dual income professionals.
Think senior managers,
successful lawyers, doctors,
consultants, tech workers, the
people pulling in say 300,000
dollars, $400,000, maybe
$500,000 a year.
The upper middle class maybe
upper class depending on your
definition, but not the mega
rich.
Exactly.
These folks are the bedrock of a
blue state city's budget, not
through splashy philanthropy,
but through the steady, boring
churn of payroll taxes, state
and city income taxes, and,
crucially, massive property
taxes on expensive homes.
They might not own the company,
but their combined tax payments
from the subway, the good public
schools, the parks, the police.
They're the invisible
scaffolding, as the source puts
it.
That's a perfect description.
And when this group gets
restless, the city's finances
don't just wobble, they
genuinely risk collapse.
And the scary part for cities
like, say, New York or San
Francisco or Chicago, is how
easily this group can inflict
that pain.
They don't need to pull up
stakes and move all the way to
Florida or Texas necessarily.
Not at all.
They just need to cross a state
line, move from Manhattan to
Jersey City, from DC to
Arlington, VA, from Boston to
Southern New Hampshire.
It's a short commute back into
the city for worker fun.
But their income tax, their
property tax, that now goes to
the other jurisdiction.
They still use the city's
infrastructure, the roads,
museums, the job market, but the
city loses their direct tax
revenue.
Precisely.
The city bears the cost, The
suburbs or neighboring state
gets the revenue.
It's the geographical arbitrage
of the tax base.
And the Washington, DC example
in the sources really drives
this home, doesn't it?
It seems like the ultimate case
study.
It's a stark warning.
DC is the economic heart.
The federal government, the
contractors, the lobbyists, the
law firms, the high paying jobs
are there.
The culture, the restaurants,
the amenities are in DC.
But where do a huge chunk of the
high earners actually live?
Maryland and Virginia, The
sources say something like 2/3
of the DC workforce commutes in.
An incredible number 2/3,
including a very large
proportion of those crucial high
income professionals.
And here's the key structural
problem for DC It lacks A
commuter tax.
It cannot tax the income earned
within its borders by people who
live just across the river in
Virginia or Maryland.
So DC pays to maintain the Metro
system that brings them in, pays
for the roads they drive on, the
police that keep downtown safe,
the museums they visit on
weekends.
But the income taxes flow to
Richmond and Annapolis, and the
hefty property taxes on those
expensive suburban homes flow to
Fairfax County or Montgomery
County.
DC is essentially subsidizing
its own tax base erosion.
It pays the cost of being the
regional hub, but a huge chunk
of the benefit, the tax revenue,
leaks out across the border.
The source calls it a clear
vision of the future for any
city that doesn't grasp the
mobility of its tax base.
It really is.
And the motivation for that
move, that decision to live in
Arlington instead of Adams
Morgan?
The sources emphasize it's
usually not about some deep
ideological commitment to
Virginia over DC.
It's simpler.
It's arithmetic as they put it.
Yes, the author shared that
personal memory of New York in
the 70s during the fiscal
crisis.
The adults weren't debating the
nuances of city policy or crime
waves when they talked about
leaving, they were doing the
math.
What's the tax bill here versus
there?
What's the cost of housing?
Just a straightforward cost
benefit analysis.
Exactly like the person quoted
living in Arlington admits they
have a good deal now, but says
flat out if the math changed,
they'd be gone.
Not if the politics offended
them, but if the numbers on
their personal balance sheet no
longer added up.
Which explains that fantastic
phrase the source uses to
describe this sensitivity, the
Princess and the P class.
Isn't that brilliant?
It captures it perfectly.
They are so attuned to their
financial comfort, their fiscal
environment, that they feel the
slightest disruption.
A politician just floats the new
millionaire's tax.
There's serious talk about rent
control expansion, a whiff of a
wealth tax proposal.
And they don't wait to see if it
passes.
No way that initial feeling of
comfort curdles into unease,
maybe even feeling targeted or
resented, and boom, they're
already making calls, looking at
properties in the cooler pan
next door.
It's pre emptive.
They leap before the policy even
gets debated.
Seriously.
Because they can.
They have the resources and the
mobility to simply opt out of
the fight.
And it's not just their money
that's mobile.
We also have to talk about the
portability of reputation.
There's another huge shift.
Historically, professionals like
doctors or lawyers were tied to
a place because they had to
build a local reputation, a
local practice over years,
right?
Yeah, your network, your clients
were all geographically based.
But that anchor is largely gone
to the source makes that great
point.
A top lawyer with New York or
London on their CV, That
credential travels better than
their luggage.
That's good.
It is because that accumulated
human capital the prestige, the
skills, the perceived quality of
migrates.
With them intact, they can land
in Miami or Austin or Denver and
immediately be seen as a premium
import, skipping years of
building local credibility from
scratch.
Geography just loses its grip.
Licenses can often be
transferred between states
relatively easily.
Now clients can be served over
Zoom.
The physical location of the
fancy office matters less and
less.
The value resides in the
individual's digital footprint,
their reputation, their portable
skill set.
And this hollowing out the
separation of value from place
even effects businesses that
seem really grounded, like a
local shop.
It does, and it shows how tricky
it is for cities to actually tax
the wealth generated within
their borders.
Take that neighborhood coffee
shop or boutique.
It pays property tax on its
physical space, sure.
But the owners?
They're likely incorporated in
Delaware for legal protection
and maybe favorable corporate
law.
They might bank with a national
or international bank based
elsewhere.
And the profits?
The profits can be structured to
flow through holding companies
or related entities located in
low tax or no tax jurisdictions.
The city sees the physical
storefront.
It can tax that, but the actual
income, the liquid wealth
generated by the business that
can be legally flowing somewhere
else entirely.
So the municipality is left
trying to tax the container, but
the valuable contents have
already been routed elsewhere.
It's a great way to put it.
They're chasing shadows.
They can hike property taxes,
hitting the physical asset, but
the real engine of profit and
capital accumulation might be
operating under a completely
different tax regime miles away.
It's a constant battle against
global financial optimization.
Which brings us right to the
core of the relationship change.
Section 4.
The psychology of taxation.
Courtship, not coercion.
If money is vapor, if reputation
is portable, then the old ways
of just demanding taxes don't
work anymore.
The whole model is flipped on
its head.
Historically, government power
rested on coercion backed by the
fact that wealth couldn't easily
flee.
Now it's all about courtship.
Aggressive, sometimes desperate
courtship.
Cities are basically running
non-stop beauty contests to
attract and retain mobile
capital and high earners.
And the Amazon HQ 2 saga was the
the ultimate example of this,
wasn't it?
Oh, it laid the whole dynamic
bear for everyone to see.
Arlington, VA won in the end.
But did they win because they
had the best schools or the
nicest parks?
No.
They won because they offered
the biggest dowry, as the source
calls it.
Exactly.
Massive tax breaks.
Promises of bespoke
infrastructure improvements
tailored just for Amazon.
Favorable zoning changes,
essentially handing over public
resources to lure a private
company.
And dozens of other cities were
doing the same thing, falling
over themselves to offer Amazon
sweetheart deals.
They were throwing themselves at
Bezos feet, competing to give
away the most public money.
Why?
Because they believed the
prestige of landing Amazon and
the secondary effects all those
high paid workers moving in.
The new business is popping up
to serve them.
The eventual rise in property
values would eventually pay back
the initial cost of the dowry.
It's an investment, sure, but
one made from a position of
weakness, right?
The city is essentially begging
the corporation to choose them.
Absolutely.
It reveals who really holds the
cards.
That frog in the pan analogy.
If a city wants to fund itself
through its high earners, it
needs very careful temperature
control.
You have to warm the water
slowly.
Exactly.
Modest tax increases, maybe fees
that feel reasonable.
Lots of emphasis on civic pride,
quality of life, making the
wealthy feel appreciated,
valued.
Keep the water comfortably warm.
But if the political rhetoric.
Changes if there are sudden,
sharp tax hikes proposed or if
the language becomes
adversarial.
Soak the rich, eat the rich.
The temperature spikes and.
The frogs leap not just across
the river this time, maybe they
leap to genuinely cooler ponds.
Florida, Texas, Nevada, maybe
even overseas to Dubai or
Singapore.
The options are global now.
The local environment feels
hostile.
They're gone.
This really highlights what the.
Sources call the erosion of
civic religion that older idea
of a mutual obligation between
wealth and the city.
Yeah, back in the 20th century
there.
Was this ingrained sense almost
a moral expectation, that great
fortunes were tied to the place
they were made?
Wealth had a responsibility to
give back.
Think of the names Carnegie,
Rockefeller, Ford on libraries,
universities, museums.
They were taxed heavily.
But also sort of revered as
patrons.
Their philanthropy was part of
the deal.
The no blessed Leech, right?
They bought public esteem.
In a way, by writing huge checks
for public benefit.
But the source argues that today
the moral framing is often
inverted.
Wealth itself is increasingly
portrayed as suspect may be
inherently unfair or even
criminal.
So when politicians use.
Rhetoric about killing
billionaires or constantly
framing the wealthy as the
enemy?
They might get applause, sure.
But they also achieve 2 things
simultaneously.
They push the tax base out the
door and they drive the private
donations.
Why would a foundation or a
wealthy family write a big check
to the local Symphony or
hospital if they feel actively
despised by the city's
leadership and a chunk of his
population?
You can't legislate gratitude.
You really can't and.
That's the core psychological
insight.
Taxation, especially at high
levels, relies on a degree of
voluntary compliance and
emotional legitimacy.
If that legitimacy erodes, if
the donors feel alienated or
attacked, the private checks
stop coming and the public tax
revenue shrinks too, because the
base is leaving.
It's a double whammy the city
ends up trying to run.
On fumes and resentment, which
leads to how cities physically
change themselves to try and
keep that legitimacy, or at
least keep the money around.
Section 5.
Urban alchemy.
The fig leaf of revitalization.
Yeah, the whole gravity is.
Reversed cities now orbit
wealth, not the other way
around.
The winning cities aren't
necessarily the ones with the
most progressive social
policies.
They're the ones with the best
amenities, the least friction
and the quickest commute to an
airport.
It's a service industry model
now, which explains why city
governments.
Seem obsessed with landing big
prestige projects.
The Olympics, A new NFL stadium,
A giant Convention Center
expansion.
These aren't just about civic
pride.
Though that's the selling point.
They function as coded
invitations to mobile wealth and
corporations.
They signal, look, we're
investing, we're clean, we're
modern, we're safe.
Please choose us.
Please build your next office
tower here.
They're chasing the secondary.
Benefits the gentrification
effect, but they can't actually
say that's the goal.
Absolutely not.
You can't.
Run for mayor on a platform of
Let's displays the poor to make
room for luxury condos.
But you can run on
revitalization or economic
development or world class
infrastructure.
So public works projects.
Stadiums, highways, waterfront
redevelopments become the
respectable excuse, the fig
leaf, as the source calls it.
Exactly.
They provide the political.
Cover to do what's necessary to
attract the desired demographic
Building a new freeway through
an old neighborhood or putting a
gleaming arena in a formerly
blighted area.
It's a polite way of signaling
to the Princess and the P class.
We're clearing out the
undesirables and creating the
polished, frictionless
environment you prefer.
And again, the DC examples are.
Really powerful here.
Nationals Park, the baseball
stadium.
That area used to be pretty
rough, right?
Navy Yard?
Yeah, it was post industrial.
Vacant lots, high crime rates.
When the stadium deal went
through using significant public
funds, it was widely slammed as
a massive billionaire subsidy
for the team owners.
But look at the area now
completely.
Transformed in.
Just a decade or so.
Michelin star restaurants,
luxury apartments everywhere,
high end hotels, big corporate
HQ's like Defend the contractors
moving in the stadium acted as
the catalyst, the publicly
funded anchor that drew in waves
of private high value investment
and the Verizon Center now
capital.
One arena did something similar
for the Chinatown area downtown.
Same playbook use a big.
Shiny public private project to
inject energy and attract
investment into an area that was
struggling.
The Source even had that little
anecdote about the 9.30 club.
Oh yeah, the music venue in the
80s.
Easy parking because the
neighborhood was sketchy, right?
No one else dared.
Go there late at night,
according to the source.
Now it's surrounded by upscale
development, tech offices,
trendy restaurants.
The revitalization follow the
path cleared by these big
projects.
So the cycle is use.
Public money for a prestige
project that draws private
investment, which leads to
gentrification, which ultimately
raises the property values and
the tax base.
Urban alchemy.
That's the formula and it
creates.
This paradox for city leaders,
Yeah, they desperately need the
increased tax revenue and
polished image that
gentrification brings to stay
fiscally solvent in this Mobile
World.
But to get it, they often have
to facilitate displacement,
using revitalization as the
justification.
The playbook works, physically
speaking, so it keeps getting
repeated.
Call IT infrastructure, and you
can bulldoze the past.
Which brings us to our final
section.
Section 6.
Portable loyalty and the end of
the anchor.
We've seen how the money moves,
why it moves moves, and how
cities try to adapt.
What's the final take away?
What's the new hierarchy?
Well, the hierarchy is
completely.
Upside down compared to 50 or 60
years ago.
Governments don't just tax the
rich anymore, they basically
audition for them.
States don't hold inherent power
over capital, they're leasing
it.
Always subject to capital
deciding to move elsewhere, the
source says.
The moment a city.
Really threatens its key
contributors.
It panics instantly.
It behaves.
Exactly like a city trying to
keep its sports team from
leaving.
The team owner threatens to
move.
The city scrambles to offer a
new stadium funded by taxpayers,
wealthy residents, or a major
employer threatens to leave or
actually starts leaving.
The city scrambles to offer new
tax breaks, regulatory relief,
other goodies.
Capital has become the ultimate.
Constituency, the one you can't
afford to alienate because it's
the only one with a credible.
Exit threat that can cripple the
entire budget overnight.
It's mobility gives it effective
veto power.
What about just love?
Of place, you know, people who
are deeply connected to their
city, their neighborhood.
The source calls them the Saints
of the urban church.
They won't leave no matter what,
right?
They exist, absolutely.
The true believers, the ones who
say this is my home, I'll fight
for it.
Even when taxes go up or
services decline.
They treat their neighborhood
like sacred ground, and the
source acknowledges them,
respects them, but they're the
exception.
They are the exception.
Yeah, most.
People, especially those in that
crucial mobile professional
class, operate more
pragmatically.
They might love their city, but
they won't martyr themselves
financially for it.
If a significantly better deal
is available just across the
river or a short flight away,
they'll find the cooler pan
rather than chaining themselves
to the hot one out of pure
nostalgia.
So for city leaders, that.
Distinction is critical.
Affection is nice, but it
doesn't pay the bills.
Love of place isn't revenue,
it's nostalgia.
It's.
Emotion.
It's no longer a reliable anchor
in the way it might have been
when leaving was genuinely
difficult or impossible.
That deep tide of geography that
allowed for high taxes and
assumed loyalty.
It's been severed by mobility.
We're in an era of portable
money.
Portable reputation and portable
loyalty.
That's the crux of it.
The.
City is now essentially a
service provider competing for
customers who can leave at any
moment, which leads to that
final.
Really, Stark thought from the
source material.
Yeah, it's quite provocative.
The simple knowledge that the
PAN has handles that exit is
always an option for those with
means changes everything.
It reframes the whole discussion
about civic duty, taxation,
belonging.
Who truly belongs to a place
anymore, in the sense of being
inescapably tied to it, the
source concludes, is only those.
Too proud or too poor to leave.
Everyone else is potentially.
Transient their loyalty
conditional on the math and the
amenities, it suggests that the
real power, the liquid wealth
that used to be the engine of
the city, has already, in a
functional sense, departed.
It exists in the cloud, globally
mobile, choosing where to alight
based on the best offer.
The city is left managing the
physical infrastructure for
whoever remains.
That is a.
Pretty sobering take away,
leaves you with a lot to think
about regarding the future of
cities and states in this
environment.
Well, certainly don't the game
today.
Our discussion centers on.
This really fundamental shift,
you know, the changing
relationship between government
and capital, specifically we're
looking at how the, well, the
mobility of wealth, how easily
it can move impacts a city's
power to tax and and fund public
services, right?
And the core question.
We're digging into based on the
material is essentially this has
the fact that wealth is so
portable now fundamentally
stripped modern governments of
their, let's say coercive taxing
power.
Are they now forced into a
constant courtship dance with
their highest earners?
Exactly, and I'll be arguing.
That yes, absolutely capital is
out of the dominant force the
old days of high, you know
compulsory taxation are
basically over when wealth and
government play that game of
fiscal chicken, wealth just wins
every time OK and I'll take the
the.
Counter position.
While I definitely acknowledge
the huge impact of capital
mobility, you can't ignore it.
I'll argue that cities still
have some pretty powerful tools.
They're effective, yes, but
indirect.
Thanks.
Strategic urban planning,
controlling amenities, building
that intellectual prestige.
Modern governments isn't
powerless, it's just changed its
tactics.
It's less about demanding
tribute, more about earning
allegiance.
Perhaps.
See, I view that less as an.
Evolution and more as a well a
collapse of government leverage.
You can trace it pretty easily.
Almost like physics.
Money.
It used to be heavy.
Think about the 1940s through
the 70s. the US could impose,
you know, these incredibly high
marginal tax rates, close to 90%
sometimes because capital was
geographically stuck.
You had physical factories,
docks, headquarters, huge
amounts of paperwork to finding
them.
You can just pick up US Steel
and move it to Bermuda
overnight.
Sure, the physical anchor was.
Stronger then right and that
whole framework.
It just vanished.
Financial deregulation, fiber
optics, instantaneous digital
transfers.
Money basically became vapor.
And crucially, this isn't just
about the billionaires.
You know, the Eduardo Severins
renouncing citizenship.
It hits hardest with what I call
the invisible scaffolding of
these high tax blue state
budgets.
That's the the 300,000 to
$500,000 dual income
professional crowd, their state
income taxes.
That's what's funding the bulk
of public care.
So when?
State or city?
Policies start to, let's say,
challenge the comfort level of
this group, like some of those
proposals discussed in New York
City.
Remember, after Zoran Mamdani's
election, things like big hikes
and high end marginal rates,
wealth taxes, their reaction is
immediate.
It's precise, it's surgical.
They don't, you know, go out and
protest.
They just do the arithmetic.
They opt out.
They move across a river, across
the state line.
You see these sudden spikes in
Greenwich condo listings,
panicked calls to Realtors in
North Jersey.
It happens fast.
And what's the result?
The city inevitably has to
concede they end up offering tax
holidays, these innovation
corridors trying to coax that
revenue stream back.
The evidence is pretty clear.
The government blinks first.
OK, I approach.
This from a slightly different
perspective.
I absolutely agree that
governments can't coerce capital
like they used to, but saying
they're therefore powerless?
I think that misunderstands the
kind of power they now wield,
often quite skillfully.
The state isn't a jailer of
capital anymore, it's more like
a a sophisticated impresario,
maybe modern revenue generation.
I think it's best understood as
a very effective courtship.
Cities lock in their tax base by
being the main producer of two
really high value assets,
prestige and amenities.
You mentioned the physical
limits of moving Standard Oil
back in the day, but today's
capital, it's often intellectual
capital, social capital.
So cities have shifted.
They're not just demanding taxes
on immovable stuff anymore.
They're hosting this massive
ongoing beauty contest for
movable investment.
We saw this play out perfectly
with the whole Amazon HQ 2
competition, didn't we?
Arlington, VA.
They didn't just capitulate,
they invested strategically.
They offered this sort of dowry,
you could call it, of
infrastructure, perks, tax
breaks.
That wasn't weakness.
That was a calculated economic
move designed to secure a
critical mass of high earning
professionals and importantly,
anchor them physically.
A dowry paid by the public,
though.
Well, yes, but with.
An expected return.
And furthermore, cities engage
in what I sometimes call urban
alchemy.
This involves these huge public
works projects, building arenas,
convention centers, redeveloping
waterfronts.
On the surface, it's about
progress and culture, but it
also serves as a politically
respectable way to frankly
displace blight and accelerate
gentrification.
And that is indirect revenue
capture.
By jacking up property values
and attracting a higher income
bracket to a revitalized area,
they boost the property tax base
exponentially.
And they do it without needing
those headline grabbing high
marginal income tax rates that,
as you said, can trigger that
flight response.
I have to push back on that.
Framing the Amazon HQ 2 saga as
a demonstration of state power
seems backward to me.
It showed state weakness.
They were forced to pay
essentially bribe for something
they once could have simply
demanded through regulation or
taxation.
And while we talk about
corporations, I want to bring it
back to the the psychological
fragility of that productive
class I mentioned earlier, the
Princess and the P class.
OK, taxation.
Fundamentally.
Relies on voluntary compliance.
It needs a certain, maybe
fragile, sense of civic
emotional legitimacy.
All this rhetoric about eat the
rich.
Sure, it's politically
energizing for some segments,
but fiscally it can be
catastrophic.
It just raises the psychological
temperature for higher earners.
It turns their comfort into,
well, palpable contempt.
Sometimes, and once a productive
professional or a major
philanthropist feels genuinely
despised by the governing class
of the prevailing mood, the
checks stop both the tax checks
and the voluntary philanthropic
ones.
Mm Hmm, we saw this.
Didn't we with those?
Specific NYC tax proposals.
They weren't just tinkering with
income tax brackets.
They were floating some pretty
radical wealth transfer ideas.
And the immediate result?
It wasn't a nuanced policy
debate.
It was a mass exodus of
financial planning.
People started making calls.
And when those private checks
dry up, the ones funding
university centers, hospital
wings, local arts foundations,
the public safety net, which
actually relies quite a bit on
private goodwill to fill the
gaps, it phrase almost
instantly.
This is a crucial
miscalculation, a temperature
mistake that government seem to
make repeatedly.
I'm sorry, but I think that
framing reduces.
Very complex urban fiscal
management, down to sort of the
wounded feelings of wealthy
individuals.
While I agree civic attachment
has certainly weakened, it's far
from gone.
The source material itself
mentions true believers, people
who genuinely treat their
neighborhood like sacred ground.
But even putting idealism aside,
cities still fundamentally
control the structural factors
that make capital want to
cluster in the 1st place.
Like what specifically?
Well, the state's power now,
really.
Lies in manipulating what you
could call the gradient of
comfort.
You brought up Brooklyn earlier.
Think about it.
Early 90s.
What high earning finance
professional wanted to live in
Brooklyn?
Very few.
Now it's a global symbol of
aspirational luxury and it
carries a massive tax base.
The actual geology didn't
change.
What changed was the
government's investment
strategy, focusing on
infrastructure, safety, schools,
cultural amenities.
Cities control the quick commute
to the International Airport,
the quality of the top tier
restaurants, access to unique
cultural institutions.
People want wealth chases,
desirability.
That is a strategic structural
lever the city can and does
pull, essentially compelling the
mobile professional to stay
where the physical ecosystem
sustains their lifestyle and,
crucially, their career.
I'm just not convinced that.
Amenity control truly overrides
the just the sheer logistical
ease of the exit strategy, the
math, it's merciless,
particularly in these border
regions, which I think really
demonstrate the failure of that
structural leverage argument.
Let's look closely at the DC
example you brought U
indirectly, it's staggering.
Something like twothirds of the
entire metro workforce lives
outside the city limits in
Maryland or Virginia.
DC has tried for decades to get
a commuter tax implemented, but
it keeps getting blocked
politically, often by Congress
itself, leaving this huge gaping
hole in their revenue.
Right, that's a specific
political.
Blockage though it is, but look
at the result.
DC ends up subsidizing the
infrastructure, the transit, the
police, the public spaces for
professionals who earn their
money in DC but pay their
crucial income taxes somewhere
else.
That hiring lawyer or lobbyist?
They only have to cross the
Potomac River, maybe move 5
miles to save 10s of thousands
of dollars a year in taxes.
That calculation is immediate.
It's powerful, and the physics
of the situation as I see it
mean the city is left chasing
shadows.
It can tax the storefront, sure,
but it can't easily capture the
corporate profits routed through
a Delaware holding company where
the income earned by someone
whose legal residence is in
McLean, VA.
OK.
But the DC scenario?
You describe that's arguably a
failure of legislative
coordination and maybe political
will between jurisdictions, not
necessarily proof that capital
itself is ungovernable.
If Maryland and Virginia rely
heavily on DC's economic engine,
well, logically they should
cooperate on revenue sharing or
find a way to implement that
commuter tax to ensure the whole
region remains viable.
Should, but don't.
Fair enough, but I want to hone.
In on your point about the
lawyer or the consultant just
needing to cross the river,
while the money certainly moves
easily, does the professional
leverage move quite so easily?
I'm not so sure.
Even these highly mobile
professions, they rely heavily
on reputation, right?
And that reputation, that
valuable asset, it's often
generated and significantly
magnified specifically within
these tier one global cities.
Think about it, a lawyer with
Wall Street on their resume or
consultant with K St. experience
that carries a certain
undeniable prestige that travels
with them.
But the actual value of that
credential, it's still tied to
the continued vibrancy, the high
density functionality of the
city that granted it.
If everyone just up and left New
York for tax reasons, eventually
New York's professional
reputation itself would atrophy,
wouldn't it?
The desire for that physical
high productivity networking
environment, the theaters, the
high end culture, the face to
face deals that still has to be
supplied locally.
The city controls the supply of
that prestige, those amenities,
and in doing so it forces wealth
to effectively pay a lease.
You could say, even if it
manages to avoid a direct tax
bill, the physical metropolis
itself acts as this
indispensable high end finishing
school for global capital.
It's an interesting point.
But we have to circle back to
the fundamental challenge that
necessitates all these tax
policies in the first place,
funding the social safety net.
I agree.
We run a kind of shadow
socialism in America.
ERS generally treat everyone who
walks in their robust food
banks.
Actual starvation is minimal
compared to history.
But maintaining even that basic
system depends utterly on
consistent revenue and
crucially, the sustained
goodwill of the productive
class.
Mm Hmm.
When government.
Attempts high.
Level coercion, or even rhetoric
that feels like coercion.
It doesn't just risk losing some
income tax revenue, it risks
destabilizing the whole system.
Look at some of those proposed
New York State tax increases.
Independent fiscal analysis
predicted they could trigger
such an exodus of professionals
earning over $1,000,000 that the
state would suffer a net loss of
revenue, not the intended gain.
It's a fiscal boomerang effect.
It proves you just cannot
legislate gratitude.
You can't tax resentment without
facing serious consequences.
The moment giving feels forced,
rather than like voluntary
participation in a shared civic
enterprise, the foundation
starts to crumble.
So we're forced to fund public
care with our eyes wide open,
knowing that if we push that
leverage too hard, the tax base
we rely on could just evaporate.
I see the policy challenge.
Definitely.
But I would frame the act of
that aggressive amenity driven
courtship, the stadium deals you
dislike, the infrastructure
perks.
I'd frame that as the necessary,
almost structural cost of
maintaining that funding stream
in this new world of highly
mobile capital.
You might call it weakness.
I'd lean towards calling it an
adapted strategy, a costly
adaptation.
Perhaps.
But consider the city's paradox.
It absolutely needs a stable tax
base to meet its social
obligations.
But often the most reliable way
left to secure the increased
revenue needed is through
revitalization projects that
require substantial private
investment.
And yes, this often involves the
displacement and gentrification
achieved via these massive
public works, frequently masked
as progress or cultural
enhancement.
Think about the history of the
Nationals Park deal in DC.
Yes, it was heavily criticized
at the time as corporate
welfare, but within a decade
that same area was filled with
luxury high rises, major defense
contractors, high end retail,
multiplying the property tax
base many times over.
This gentrification, however
politically sensitive it might
be, seems to be the most
reliable, if indirect mechanism
cities have left to secure the
higher property and payroll
taxes they need to stabilize
that safety net.
The city is applying indirect
coercion, maybe aimed at
geographical improvement, which
in turn attracts the revenue,
rather than applying punitive
taxation aimed directly at the
individual's balance sheet.
I still have to challenge.
The idea that this alchemy, as
you call it, is truly
sustainable or even morally
neutral in the long run.
It often requires the city to
effectively sell off pieces of
its geography to private
interest at a deep discount,
offering long term tax
abatements like TIF districts
that significantly undermine
future tax capacity just to
secure current residency.
So the central tension for me
remains exactly where we
started.
We are trying to apply a 20th
century model of public finance,
one that fundamentally relied on
capital having mass having
roots, having loyalty to a 21st
century reality where money and
professional loyalty right along
with it are almost entirely
portable.
Governments today, like it or
not, are forced into this
permanent orbit around wealth
and any tax policy, no matter
how well-intentioned or socially
necessary it might seem.
If it mistakes wealth for an
immovable captive asset, well,
it's just fiscally and
politically doomed from the
start.
The exodus isn't driven by
passionate protest.
It's triggered by cold hard
arithmetic.
The power dynamic has.
Undeniably flipped.
I grant you that.
Cities are forced to audition
now, not demand tribute.
However, the successful outcomes
of this urban alchemy we've
discussed, like those
significant lasting increases in
the tax base around major public
amenity investments, they prove,
I think, that cities can still
generate an almost irresistible
gravitational force.
They still control key variables
that the wealthy and the capital
they manage are compelled to
chase.
Concentrated professional
opportunity, world class quality
of life.
So it's about tone then in.
Large part, yes.
The decision for a city becomes
less about whether to tax or not
tax, and more about maintaining
that welcoming, attractive tone
and continuously delivering the
tangible benefits that justify
the admittedly high price of
admission.
The truly successful city in
this new era is the one that
masters the art of crafting an
irresistible lease agreement.
You might say, but the fact.
Remains the.
Capital and the highly skilled
professionals who manage it,
they know they're sitting in
that proverbial pan of water and
they all know perfectly well
they can hop out the moment the
temperature rises too high.
And that self-awareness.
That knowledge that the
competition is always active,
it's constant, that is
fundamentally altered the
relationship between government
and the governed.
It confirms the game is far from
over, certainly, but the rules,
they have been forever changed.